m e les yeux je te promets que tu va
dépasser les rêves les plus fous twin
peaks le phénomène événement qui a
révolutionné la télévision s'attaque
maintenant au monde du blu ray avec une
édition complète est exceptionnel comme
si je faisais le pipeau terrine pics
l'intégrale prestige bourré regroupe
tous les épisodes de la série culte dans
des gorets haute définition avec une
toute nouvelle image retravaillée à
partir de pellicule qui viennent d'être
retrouvés avec un sont spectaculaires et
pour la première fois
retrouvez également dans ce coffret
inédit twin peaks fire walk with me le
film sur les origines de la série qui
illustre les derniers jours de leur à
palmer qui mèneront à sa mort prématurée
réalisé à partir de nouveaux scans au
format 4k tirer des pellicules originale
du film est supervisé par david lynch
autres vefa you walk with me comme vous
ne l'avez jamais vu et enfin ce que les
fans attendaient depuis longtemps des
scènes coupées réalisé et monté par
david lynch lui même toutes issues de
fire walk with me le saint graal pour
tous les femmes de twin peaks
ce coffret composé de dix cours est
contient une mine d'argyle ainsi que de
nombreux bonus inédits tournés pour
l'occasion dont le court métrage en deux
parties autres de monde dans lequel
david lynch lui même interview les
membres de la famille palmer under the
banner suivie d'une discussion avec les
acteurs qui les incarnent à l'écran
et h retrouvez aussi pour chaque épisode
d introduction de la femme à la bûche
transféré à partir de pellicule
originale que l'on croyait perdus des
scènes coupées des images inédites de la
série et bien plus encore vous pensiez
tout connaître le twin peaks mais vous
n'avez rien vu tant que vous n'avez pas
regardé la série dans ces conditions
idéales
je n'avais pas été aussi excité depuis
la forge et trancher la route de
caroline twin peaks l'intégrale prestige
blu-ray éclaircies enfin le mystère avec
pratiquement une heure et demie de
scènes coupées de fire au quiz mais
disponible le 29 juillet en blu ray je
ne sais pas trop où cela
mais j'ai la ferme confiance et peut
être qu'à un lieu aussi magnifique
qu'étrange